this is now my my going out in London
experience sorry for the context I
stayed in cuz um I wasn't feeling well I
was hurt in pain yeah go ahead
so so yeah this is so there's this place
called the box there's one in New York
and there's one here and I don't know if
there's one was a body that's what he
wrote the song about yeah very well
could be dude sorry what after you hear
this it very well could be what songs
about who knows yeah yeah so um yeah
just going it's this club that I guess I
don't know if it's any it's probably in
like other major cities too but it's
like super notorious like it's it's
infamous I've heard about it many a time
never gone because it's super [ __ ]
hard to get an apparently yeah and all
I've heard about it is that it they put
on insane shows yeah and it's different
every single time you never know what
you're gonna get it's it's going to blow
your mind and you're gonna end your like
you're gonna leave that place being like
what the [ __ ] did I just watched real
quick Elena's cousin came to the show
last night and he was like leave you go
to the box I'm like I'm thinking about
it and he was like I don't just scene
man I'm like why is like last time I was
there someone was [ __ ] on stage I
was like what yeah and he was like he's
like and that was it it was just
[ __ ]
I don't like oh [ __ ] I like I already
don't feel good I'm like yeah maybe I'm
good he's like he's like he's like I
don't think it's for you so I'm like all
right I'm with it that's what the other
guy wanted ksi his friends he said that
damn [ __ ] uh the boy Cal frizzy or
yes Cal frizzy yes sorry yeah Cal frizzy
yeah it's all boy or that minam eight or
was Nelson with Nelson Yeah right sorry
I'm [ __ ] awful with names thought it
to you guys though yeah they're really
nice the side man yeah boys there was no
and will any to yeah okay so so I've
never been to this way oh yeah so Cal
frizzy said that
the only other time he's been there same
sort of thing someone [ __ ] on it pizza
and like threw it into the crowd or so
but I like I'm like I'm like it has to
be fake first of all and second of all
oh [ __ ] I just didn't think that I was
like I have to see this with my own eyes
also love I love weird [ __ ] like this
mmm
a guy like Mike [ __ ] Devin and I in
Amsterdam went it like this sex show we
just like watched these two people [ __ ]
onstage okay just me and my boy
I love weird [ __ ] like where you know it
makes you good like something it makes
you genuinely feel like yeah I've never
seen this before
yeah fair know that feeling we were like
oh my god this is a new feeling I've
gotten in life yeah a new thing I've
seen you rarely get that [ __ ] anymore
yeah and well you get [ __ ] at the box
for sure you get you yeah that's yeah
yeah so we get there oh yeah so you know
we're lucky enough to get in thanks to
ksi so this is the first time I've ever
been in this place I don't think we
could have gotten in yeah um really I
don't I don't know he handle it so I
don't know here like a promoter the line
was pretty [ __ ] like huge and also
the bouncers were very very mean oh and
we showed up and said his name and it
still took like 15 minutes finally I was
like all right for if you can come in
whoa yeah and so uh we get in and it's
it's going off like we have this table
like near the back and everyone not
nobody there is a general admission
everyone has a table oh and everyone's
standing on the seats and it's going
crazy and it's very very small like I
would say it's probably like double the
size of this room and there's a giant
stage that comes through the middle that
like is a semicircle at the end so
there's tables wrapped around it and
then there's a main stage at the back
little [ __ ]
and so the first act comes on it's like
this girl that's dressed up in lingerie
she got this insane voice and she starts
singing and it's like a singing number
ends and we're like oh then that was
like pretty great as far as shows go
like live shows at a club that was
amazing yeah the second one comes on I
don't even know if I can like I pretty
sure they like make you sign an NDA when
you walk into this place or some [ __ ] I
don't know if I can talk about this but
you sign this you signed something no
but I feel like I had that bag that yeah
it's just like
understanding that if you go you don't
talk about it oh [ __ ] that I'm I think
I'm gonna go so the second act this
chick this crane comes down from the
ceiling and she comes out on stage and
she's dressed up and like sort of like a
kimono and she's got a blindfold around
her face and she attaches the crane hook
on to her hair and it pulls her up in
the air and she does this whole number
where she strips and spins around just
by her hair the whole time okay and it's
like super weird and sexual and cool and
and dope all right she finishes that and
we're like damn that was really cool
that was really cool okay little messed
up that she was hit being held by her
hair the whole time but still very cool
right what could the next one be are
they gonna top that it makes what the
next one is this dude that has clown
makeup on okay horrifying clown makeup
okay I'm talking like this [ __ ] straight
from you ever watch that video I did on
that on ASMR and there's that dude that
had that mask on that's like rubbing the
mic with his knife I can't remember
horrifying make up like a clown make up
and he's got he's got giant fake boobs
okay and then he is like almost naked or
is kind of wearing like a maid's outfit
or something like that okay he takes his
boobs out okay and then and then he's
got a he's got a a guy tied up naked on
a stage and he takes a knife and he
basically insinuate so he's like cutting
the guy's dick off or something like
that okay or maybe like slicing his leg
or something okay cuz he has his blood
on his hand all of a sudden oh he gets
up on stage turns his ass towards
everyone and starts fisting his own ass
with the blood covered hands so
so that was the next thing like I don't
and we're all like everyone in the club
is like what so what is it like they
were trans like what or is it just like
hard to say because the makeup just like
was not telling I didn't even know if
the boobs were real oh I don't even know
if they were like real fake boobs they
might have just been like a like one of
those like where yeah yeah whoa whoa the
clown makeup I mean it wasn't even like
I didn't even know no fair yeah yeah
yeah and good hair though and no he's
wearing wig Oh crazy like coffee
crazy wig word so he's fisting his own
ass with with his blood blood soaked tan
from the I'm sorry if this is like
disgusting to you right now it's more
funny to me because it's like we were
all just like winces from oh this yeah
like yes halation
well it's like it's like you know it had
this sense of like oh wow yeah yeah and
she's like spinning around her body's
all like you know she's pointing her
toes and she's like heart or something
sorry it's me feels like dance yeah yeah
to this like shock yeah value show yeah
and so we're like okay that was wild the
next one comes out as two dudes and
they're contortionists okay and they do
this crazy like pop lock dance moves
where they're like popping their
shoulders out and [ __ ] like that
was wild but like also a little bit
gross and then and then there was
another show that was like kind of
normal and then the clown comes back out
and it gets naked completely naked and
he takes his dick and he just pees all
over all the people that were sitting at
the table surrounding the stage so these
are the most expensive tables at this
club I mean they're probably like
thousands of pounds and this dude is
just peeing all over them and we watched
boobs or no boobs boobs like look so
they were real then yeah but it could
have been like makeup like it could have
been like a fake set of boobs that he
put I don't know word okay word I just
got to get the babies right I gotta make
sure the boobs are on or off boobs are
the boobs are their boot breasts are
there yeah breasts are there it's he's
on everyone
yeah whoa yeah that feels like some like
a high-art
like rich person shaming [ __ ] how did
the people respond like were they hissed
upset yeah they were all like rushing to
the bathroom to like dry themselves off
and stuff like that but I don't know but
then again it weirdly like then oh the
the host came back onstage they original
chick with the with the pipes yeah check
that was belting it out at the start and
she basically was like calling them
[ __ ] and like and saying oh you're
sad you got a little whatever and then
like was kind of berating them and so it
it it almost like dissolve the tension a
little bit word it's so [ __ ] hard to
explain
yeah without actually being there no of
course it was just the wildest show like
yeah I've I've I've ever never no I mean
that that to me is like that's um yeah
that's like some weird like art [ __ ]
and then it happens and then they're
they're you know breaking down I don't
know social norms through [ __ ] art
yeah show and yeah yeah now that makes
it interesting yeah it does make it
interesting
hey wild a little piss on your [ __ ]
you know high-class garments yeah boohoo
taking home throw your wash exactly
[ __ ] cry about something else on the
Gucci sterile you idiot and every
cleaner now yeah drink it yeah that's
that's that's not just any pee yeah
that's been different like this that's
fresh clown fist in the ass pee and you
should be thankful you got some of that
pee so stop [ __ ] complaining you know
man it was wild you can you can get a
Gucci jacket anywhere but you can't get
that man's piss yeah from that night
exactly that's the rare part oh yeah
that's the designer part yep you should
[ __ ] you should laminate that part of
the fabric with the piece soaked in
exactly
exactly dude I'm so glad I went to sleep
oh my god wild wild I mean we definitely
left that place being like that was you
one of the craziest nights we've ever
had oh for sure yeah yeah no I never see
[ __ ] like that no also like it's like
illegal to do that right you can't just
pee on people you can't it's true let's
see what happens at our show let's just
take a whiz on somebody just a quick
whizz see if any yeah anybody just try
the same thing at our show and get
[ __ ] nailed with a lawsuit
yeah no no you can't pee on people he
actually can't pee on anyone damn that's
crazy yeah yeah part of me wishes I
could have been a fly on the wall
another part of me thinks that the fist
in the ass might have put me away yeah
cuz it's one thing to see it in a video
because you're desensitized to that kind
of shake like ass shocker porn whatever
yeah but to see a human actually be like
hey you want to see a magic trick
yeah like what's up you know some with
cards not even better dude I mean like
or is it I honestly didn't mind the fist
in the ass I was like this just I mean
it just it's it's like watching a sex
show or whatever you just watching
someone do some crazy [ __ ] so their body
with the blood that's what got me yeah
the blood was like oh [ __ ] this is
another dudes blood that I don't know if
that's real or not and I did way that
this is going right now I kind of um
think it's real because I don't think
they cut corners or the whole point is
is to commit a [ __ ] shock you and to
go all the way
damn but then again I don't know if the
piss was real because you can't just but
he's his dick was Audi I saw it come out
of his dick yeah yeah wild wild well
damn was JJ's reaction all that was he
just like ah sure I'll just like the
whole time and then we never we just
left and then none of us ever like
decompressed or like you know unpacked
what we just saw so now this is me doing
that right now yeah I kind of wish I
went to see like what my threshold would
have been yeah cuz I say it would have
been gross now but it could have been
one of those things
yeah like I would've been in the MonaVie
like Dan that's just a fist in the butt
yeah that's crazy
yeah and just looked at it would lock
the eyes oh yeah it was going in to like
just it was crazy sorry sorry if that
makes you I just feel like yeah yeah
yeah if you weren't gonna throw up yeah
I need it's a really go we need to put a
warning you need to put a warning on
this episode we just need to put in
parens graphic every [ __ ] episode
ends up like that now yeah I know I know
it does end up grass and I wish I wish I
could be like cool enough to be like man
I don't talk about what happens at the
box you know I go there and lock that to
see the show and think about what it
means and like I'm not I don't share
that with people who have a bit know I
saw that's like now I got to talk about
this [ __ ] that dude while this shows
I've ever seen my entire that's [ __ ]
price I've seen some [ __ ] pricing people
out of that [ __ ] get out of here yeah no
yeah come on man yeah you want that big
money go on tour yeah
take the fist in the ass show on tour
yeah put it in arena yeah put some
cameras on it if I can make people pay
twenty thousand pounds yeah that's
horseshit yeah make the people in the
front row pay the twenty thousand pounds
to get peed on but that's it yeah but I
do understand like for the context of
the show making it limited yeah I
understand yeah you know whatever ya
know it makes it like yeah it's just
that element of like exclusivity where
you're like I need to be paid yeah yeah
also like the waitresses were all like
like like drinking with us hmm
like they'd bring around the champagne
and they'd pour themselves a glass too
and they'd like they were all kind of in
character okay kind of cool all right
it was cool it was cool yeah he had
people dressed up in lingerie of like
all different like you know shapes sizes
like every sort of type of person you
can think of okay it was they were like
part of the show part of the
entertainment it was cool yeah all right
now now I need to know from people who
like consume you know performance art I
want to know someone who's like you paid
for that [ __ ] yeah man just go down to
the FATA for 30 quid yeah hey Quinn man
you get you see a fist and honest all
night well I want to know
that place yes I wanna know the [ __ ]
yeah you go down some stairs bro yeah I
want to know the open mic version of
that oh no I don't want to know the open
mic version of that because you know
there definitely is oh yeah yeah you
know I didn't just debut at the bar hell
nah nah he worked up to the box I want
to see the people you know on the come
up yeah you know literally dude I don't
know comes up on something I don't know
I want to see that gotta be something
they do yeah yeah they got it there's
got to become does a cone show I'm at
the box I'm saying like what Wednesday
nights maybe it's like the calm night
yeah oh yeah bro it's coming Sunday
you